لا مشجعي كره القدم احذروا الحماس المفرط
فقد يؤدي الى ذبحه صدريه
[موسيقى]
حديثه كشفت ان مشاهده مباريات كره القدم
تمتلك تاثيرا سلبيا على القلب ونصحت
بالتخفيف من الحماس المبالغه فيه
ووفقا للدراسه فان مشاهده الاحداث
الرياضيه قد تؤثر على القلب والاوعيه
الدمويه عن طريق رفع مستويات التوتر
العاطفي بالاضافه الى زياده ضغط الدم
ومعدل ضربات القلب بشكل ملحوظ وبالمثل
كانت تصلب الشرايين اعلى وظل مرتفعا ايضا
[موسيقى]
الباحثون لاحظوا ان المشاركين في الدراسه
عن يوم ارتفاع في ضغط الدم ووصول معدلات
ضربات القلب الى مستويات خطيره خلال
المباريات الحاسمه كما بقيت القراءات
عاليه لعده ساعات بعد المباراه كما تبين
ان الاثاره الناتجه عن اللعبه تؤدي الى
زياده المستويات هرمون الاجهاد
هذه النتائج تدعم الدراسات السابقه التي
اظهرت ان الضغط الناجم عن مشاهده فرق كره
القدم اثناء المنافسات الكبيره يمكن ان
يكون له اثاره قاسيه وبما اننا نشهد موسم
كاس العالم هذه الايام بات الحضروا واجبا